[Music]
hello everyone I'm gunmaster Dennis
Bosch and this is prepare like a pro now
this actually won't be just preparing
like a pro
cess but more like prepare like a world
champion
so many of you and I see all the people
here are excited about the match between
Ding and Napoli
so what we're going to take a look at is
a perspective of how potentially the
world champion prepared now I don't have
the leaked information this is a PSA I
don't know what's going in their
preparation this is my take of how I
think preparation went for team
napomniaci
um so we're actually not going to focus
on the game itself that was played that
is your homework to do
not mine and we're just going to focus
on what potentially may have inspired
Napo to play the way he did
now whenever you play an opponent you
sort of want to know what's the ballpark
you sort of expect there's an opening
so if you talk about openings
um we kind of know what first move we'll
see any ideas what first movie would see
and if you are a Fisher fan you can go
wrong
so just a bit of a hint these are the
two main moves hope these are the two
main moves and my arrow play is not the
strongest but it works
yes for E4 yes so E4 and usually it
leads to E5 this is not necessarily the
only move but it's sort of played
exclusively at the top especially by the
Chinese Grandmaster ding leran
um anybody else they often play C5 and
we're talking about this this has been
played in the match Carlson and karwana
where famously Carlson went for the
swashnikov so if you think that ah chess
is fairly tedious everyone is just
playing E5 that's not the case many
players switch it up they play C5 they
even play D6 this world championship
which hasn't been played for a long time
now the last time E6 so the French was
played was the Corp of Court snowy
matches which if you know a lot about
Chess history
me do
wasn't exactly of a championship it's
supposed to be basically the candidates
finals who would meet Fisher but Fisher
of course never showed up and that never
really materialized however
practically we can say that it was in
the carp of Court snowy matches where
korchner played the French a lot and the
last time this time E6 was played in the
ding uh Napo miyachi match but back to
our topic whenever you're preparing
you're sort of preparing for the most
likely Choice E5 is by far the most
popular choice among the elite players
and of course it trickles down uh to
lower levels as well now
E4 E5 in fact makes a lot of sense
because it not only gives you the square
in the middle it also restricts your
opponent and even though we talk a lot
about Center play I really hope other
lectures do talk about it wanna hear
some nods yes I can even hear it yes
good so it's all about who controls more
in the middle that is the reason why
moderns are not that popular because the
more space you get the more likely
you're going to control the game because
you can restrict your opponent's play
they can't really move pawns anymore to
either C5 or E5 because I already
occupied that square with my Pawn
so E5 is a pretty pretty good move
because not only does Dane would capture
more space but he also restricts White's
play now that doesn't always stop people
from playing F4 but we're going to
leave it at that and all the kings
Gambit experts
so Knight F3 Knight C6 Bishop B5 so the
topic of the day if you're just joining
is how nepo probably prepared for his
match is white
in this opening anybody know the name of
this opening
yes the Spanish this is the Spanish
variation
um so people play
Bishop B5 if they're extremely serious
this has been played by most of the
super Grand Masters including the
legendary world champions now if we want
to divide the ranking in the world and
it's sort of like an official ranking
we'd say we've got
super Grand Masters who are very very
high rated and we've got players who
sort of hall of fame or legendary the
legendary one is my extra take that's
how I would call them
um so Bishop B5 has been played by
Kasparov Carlson Anand everyone big and
great player has played the Spanish with
white
there are other moves that has getting
more uh popular but it doesn't make this
less relevant even today so he continues
on so Knight F6 has been played in
another game but most of the time
A6 and Bishop E7 is played okay so
before we immerse ourselves in these
games which are basically some examples
of how to play this opening
what are the big big openings in the
Spanish there's actually two one two big
ones and both of them are fairly dreaded
yes go ahead
um well you could allow the Marshall
once you could play like a closed
yeah so one of the openings that's kind
of dreaded and it's not really played uh
or isn't played in this match is this
one and D5 now this uh whole idea has a
big history so the inventor Frank
Marshall from America
um he hid this preparation for years so
he can spring it on the legendary world
champion
capablanca now unfortunately for him it
didn't quite work out capablanca won the
game but still uh the name stuck and
it's called The Marshall Gambit black
practically sacrifices upon
but what black gets in return and uh
just for historic notice Knight F6 was
played in that game but that has been
superseded by this Palm move Bishop D6
and queen H4
and even though white is up a pawn these
Bishops are so strong
and the attack is so naturally flowing
that oftentimes white just decides to
avoid this whole line
so this is something that dingler and
plays all the time so there comes the
big question when you're preparing for a
world championship match are you going
to test your opponent in the very Main
Line This is the very very main line of
the opening or are you going to play
something different
so it goes for D3 he's avoiding it all
together now
if we're going down to the basics
you have to remember
that the point of Bishop B5
is to threaten to capture on C6
now at this moment though it doesn't
quite work
takes takes it doesn't quite work in the
sense that if you capture on E5 then I
have this move of Queen D4 double
attacking the pawn and the Knight so
basically you can't win the pawn
now this is of course a complex of its
own and played by Fisher in some of his
matches but Bishop A4 is considered to
be the best
now does anybody know what is the
strategy involving uh there's Bishop B5
to A4 move if you're talking about pins
we're talking pins here
although this is not a really classic
pen but a pain a pen nonetheless
I'd still call it a pen
so why is this move going to A4 so good
any guesses why this move could be good
so one of the points of pinning
is that the Knight can't really move
away
because it will have dire effects on the
King right
so if you move this bishop anywhere or
you capture you're sort of releasing the
tension
so the goal that you set out to have
will never actually go to full effect
so the reason you get your Bishop to A4
is that you retain your threat and your
pressure along this diagonal
and that's actually something very
important to remember
because if you don't follow through your
plans oftentimes it's very very hard to
pinpoint your mistakes so even though
your plan may be flawed this way or the
other it's a good idea to still go
through with it because then you learn
that ah I'm a genius actually or you
realize oh maybe I'm not such a genius
after all but you'd never know if you
just capture on C6 because you sort of
defeated your own concept
is that clear make sense okay so Bishop
A4 Knight F6 castles
Bishop E7 anytime they go D6 which would
be a very logical move then we already
have this pin going on
now there are some ideas that's very
important to remember you usually want
to defend this Pawn
and then get this Pawn to C3 because if
you go D4 they actually can shut out
this bishop on A4
this is actually very very famous uh
little trick in this position for black
has an important idea which is sort of
still related to this opening so if we
are already discussing the Roy Lopez or
the Spanish it's usually called let's
try to find the way so if you're
thinking for your opponent's side
they're sort of uh playing defense
they're trying to stop you from
achieving your goals
for the moment white is trying to use
this whole pin along this A4
E8 diagonal how can we try to reduce
that or minimize that effect
chess is actually very straightforward
if you decide okay I don't like you
Bishop you just attack if it's something
of a lower value
and that's that's how it goes
okay
all right okay I understand that's okay
it's okay to be shy
um which piece are you thinking of
moving you don't have to move you don't
have to tell me what move
tell me a piece
it's black
okay
um
yeah or you can push you could push you
could go here
why not be
B5 yeah yeah
and that actually that's correct in fact
the move that you should be playing and
actually both of your ideas are spot on
so Bishop D7 is a bit more timid
but you're basically unpinning yourself
and in fact it's an important technique
to remember because now you will never
ever be in trouble oftentimes when
people get in trouble is that they
forget to unpin and then I pin you and
because it's illegal to move the Knight
you are going to lose something Knight
upon
etc etc now B5 here is actually very
strong and most of the times they do
push this b-pump because it chases away
the bishop and it vents time because of
course the pawn is worth is just so low
so Bishop B3
and now here comes the Trap exactly
here comes the Trap and anybody yeah go
ahead
yes so you take with the Knight
um because it kind of clarifies the
situation now if you are more cautious I
advise you to take with the pawn first
but the idea is the same
because there is no Palm moves
C5 attack your queen you move the queen
C4 and the bishop on B3 is trapped
and this is I can tell you the most
painful way to lose a piece why because
it's basically undone by your own pawns
if you would have any Escape swears on
A2 or C2 you'd be still fine
but because of that your Bishop is
trapped you could take here but then of
course it's still just down a piece for
nothing
so this is actually a very important
idea to remember
either if you don't want to fall for it
as white
or as for black if you want to trap your
opponent's Bishop but back to the game
so Bishop E7 it still doesn't work
because then they take the pawn so
the gist is that you really can take
this Pawn unless if you defend the
e-pawn
so once D3 is played if you wouldn't
defend it
because of the fact that I defended my
e-pawn already I can't take yours
so that's kind of the connection here
so B5 D6 is basically very similar
position
C3 castles A4 Bishop D7
so all very standard okay now
before again we get into the
nitty-gritty
um
let's think about pieces that are pretty
horrendous for us as white it's actually
a good way of playing chess which one of
your pieces are
badly placed
which one you could improve upon
the Knight which one
yep
where would you put it
yeah
Bishop C2 but they're going to play
Knight D2 now so this is sort of
interchangeable what makes these Spanish
positions interesting this is not your
smash buckling very sharp positions
these are more about strategy now it's
not that tactics don't happen ever
but it's more about
the strategy at least in the early phase
of the game
so now D2 very very good and that's
actually the way you play this you
realize oh my pieces are awful let me
just maneuver it to a better Square
Bishop f8
Knight F1
D5 D5 is also a very interesting move
however I'm curious what do you guys
think of this
is that just a pure positive to play
this D5 move
you know I'm very curious your take chat
as well is this a pure positive
or there's some downsides to this move
so I got the fairly simple answer of
nope however that explains a lot I mean
nothing
yeah it does weaken the E5 Pawn over
there so
chance is a game of give and take blank
decides to play Pawn to D5 and that
helps you to get a foothold in the
center however once they're going to be
a trade as happens in the game this Pawn
that used to be valguarded is a target
early on you had this very nice Pawn
structure which made sure there's no
apparent immediate weakness the position
once you play Pawn to D5 yes you gain so
you could have more active please pieces
to play and peace placements but you're
kind of weakened your structure which
kind of translates that in the long term
you may face trouble
however you know there's the benefits of
you can't position your pieces to a
better square but okay let's continue D5
takes so one of the benefits that you
get in this position is that you get the
knight in the center
so Bishop D2 B4 E5 now A5 is a key move
so as we're looking through this
Maze of ideas of the rule Lopez we have
to sort of Mark ideas that are key
and A5 is a key idea now but for that we
gotta wonder what could be the point of
this Palm move
yes
you're trying to fix the pawn on A6 that
is true okay
could there be some hidden agenda behind
this Palm move
yeah it does block the a pawn and it
potentially can be a Target yes that's
correct Dennis Eldridge that is correct
but there is some other ideas
related to this
yes Bishop A4 so
the best moves in chess are moves that
have many full ideas behind them
so the fact that we fix this Pawn
meaning the weak Pawn that will be
attacking all the time
can't move at all but also we set up an
idea such as Bishop to the A4
harassing that Knight on C6 and putting
pressure on the e-pawn
so these are those moves that seem
innocious and tepid but in reality
they're very very very good because
you're setting up multiple threats not
just one
and by the way if you guys have any
questions and that goes for chat do feel
free to ask away I'll be more than happy
to respond
so be ticks be ticks Knight F6 so Knight
F6 is sort of a prophylactic idea trying
to put it on the Square where the Knight
isn't loose
at F6 Knight G3
Rook B8 and here comes Bishop A4
Bishop D6 over defending the pawn on E5
so at the moment you could kind of argue
that it's a balanced position however
potentially that's a Target and this
could be a Target too
now if you may be wondering Knight takes
A5 doesn't work because I can capture
here The Rook on E8 is hanging if you
take here I take here
here I often see the knights next to
each other on F3 and G3 what's the use
of that so the use of having these
Knights they're kind of like extra
Defenders for your king now normally you
have Pawns in front and they're the
Bodyguards of your king
and that's just like extra helpers out
there
but also they control some crucial
squares in this position like they
control
Center squares mostly so if you don't
know what you're doing in general make
sure your piece controls the Square
close to the metal
and there's a high chance you'll be
doing the right thing sure thing Aditya
so Bishop D6 Queen C2 Knight A7
okay
all right so we talked about the
position but we didn't really talk about
this thing called space right we didn't
talk about it
let's talk about it then so space
and the world we live in
who has more space here
it's not a trick question it's either
white or it's black
um I would say you know why probably in
the queen side
so the way you could tell
this is sort of the demarcation line for
both sides
if you manage to break through that
that means you're sort of pushing your
opponent off the board
if you can manage to get into their
territory it's more likely you have the
space Advantage correct
someone's asking was the Dark Matter
that's a Sagan question so we're not
going to
encroach on Carl Sagan territory just
yet
so A5 and we have that Palm fixed other
than that it's sort of even in the
center and I would kind of say that
in general if it there's sort of a
standstill in the middle but you have a
little bit of extra space on the side
you're more likely to have the advantage
or the slightest of Advantage the best
Advantage if you control the metal
all right so Bishop B3 do that if you
don't know is fairly well known for his
fighting Spirit as you'll see Queen
Bishop E6 trades trades D4 just trying
to open up in the middle Knight C6 Rook
D1
he takes D4
and this next move is somewhat
surprising but not really if you sort of
understand the themes of chess
uh the themes of Chess is always
creating more weaknesses right
so how can Duda the legendary polish
player create more Targets in this
position
yes
Rook takes very good
so in general you want to have a smooth
Bond structure that all of your pawns
are hugging your king
there's no extra danger in that case
however this structure is somewhat
broken it's kind of a bad swiss cheese
very stinky
takes
and now there's two weaknesses in the
position not just one so according to
all chess knowledge two weaknesses that
could be enough for a victory
because if you double attack they'll
have to choose and one of them false
Queen E8 rookie one
Rook B5 trying to attack
94 takes Queen takes Queen D7
so the maneuvering phase kind of ends
right here right here and right now
however Duda comes up with an
excruciatingly nice move here
Duda is a real fighter and whenever he
can prolong the battle he will find the
way
if a vendi for our week two well they're
way more guarded and it's easier to
defend them
then oh
easier to defend these pawns than the
ones on E6 and A6
so we talked about the fact that white
king is safer right one skin is much
safer because there's no scattered uh
Pawn structures there
and actually here Duda comes up with a
move that is somewhat shocking but not
entirely shocking
yes
pontics
so once we sacrifice
we have to be very aggressive with our
next moves because otherwise we just run
out of time and then we say good game GG
your next move has to be an aggressive
move
so aggressive move it usually means it's
going to be a check
okay
mean G4 yeah that's one way
yeah
so I'll tell you a bit of a secret
so whenever we're trying to figure out
chess
one of them is reason and one of them is
intuition so if you follow the idea and
say okay I think Queen G6 is something
that I feel or I believe might be the
answer or the right move
try it
there's nothing to lose and a whole lot
to gain because you may just actually
hit on the right move
now you can make the move of course it
can backfire obviously but on the other
hand
oftentimes it's a big Advantage if you
trust your intuition follow through with
it and then try to prove it
because sometimes VR on our own worst
enemies
we are actually trying way too hard
and we just did say it ourselves from
playing the move that we thought in the
first place
I did that just recently I was really
mad
so it happens to the best of us it ain't
for me so Queen G6 it actually was
played
um
but it really the bottom line is that
trusting your uh gut is not necessarily
a bad idea although at the end of the
day you will have to prove it
how it works
Queen G6 very good so if Queen G7
there's a reason why this is horrible
yes go ahead
yeah there's Queenie a check and we pick
up the Knight on C6
and it's basically a game because on the
highest level because Black's King is
very vulnerable
and uh also there's plenty of Pawns that
are going to fall
so they can go Queen G7 they go King age
eight which surprisingly is a mistake
Queen takes H6
Queen H7
queen queen F6
Queen G7
now the question is though what if Black
Goes King G8
now what makes chess a bit more
complicated is that you always have to
be on the lookout for your opponent's
moves and their ideas of maybe even
meeting us
I know that's nasty but that's how the
game works
they can even try to meet us so if we
would want to take here
problem is they might just background
check us and that does not look good
takes under
I heard some ideas
it's okay there's no such a thing as a
move
every move that has an intention is a
good move
and I actually even suspect what you
said
I think I heard you
and if you don't mind I'll share it if
that's okay
it's okay
all right so I believe you were thinking
of moving the Knight right
no so
that's why I wanted to talk about it
um this move
actually would be pretty good
if not for Black's counter play
so you are not was defending this Square
now you sort of left it hanging
but if I wouldn't have that idea this
move would be very very strong because
the queen usually is working very well
with the combination of the night
so if I would just move away then you
just take here and you are setting up
plenty of threats
so in general it's a good idea to
involve the Knight with the queen
unfortunately we do run into this idea
but that does not diminish the fact that
this is a viable way of playing the game
okay
I hope that answered Knight G5
so here the best move is to take on E6
after this we can't even just go here
and take another pawn and we actually
are up a ton of Pawns at this moment
I've got like three pawns and that's
exactly the value of a piece plus the
king is sort of uh Breezy over there on
G7
okay so Queen G7 was played
Queen takes E6
and here
listen to his inner Yasser and took the
Palm what a mistake you can only do it
if you're a yase
but Knight D4 is a grave Brave mistake
and it is white to move
and win the game
so oftentimes that is a giveaway is to
just decide which part of the board
you're going to look at which side of
the board should we look at and I'm
asking everyone including you chat
live audience
check the miserable King
and you know
check with purpose
never in spite
okay but are you checking with purpose
or just despite you no
okay
um
okay so check
here
I'm following I'm trying to follow
you know so it's fine I'm following so
checking
okay
if I move my Bishop
then
yep
so
it makes sense and I appreciate the fact
you're trying to involve as many as you
possibly can and that's the way you
should do it
the more pieces you have attacking the
better yes go ahead
um does uh Queen E8 win the night
um
if you block with the with the queen you
can just exchange and take yes but what
if I don't what if I go here and then
just Queen uh Queen E4 right and then
you need four okay I can move my Knights
oh
Queen what yeah so we can quite go these
squares because it's guarded by that
sneaky Rook on B5
yep so that that doesn't quite work
so
most of you try to involve as many
pieces as possible
you haven't quite considered the idea of
luring away the defender
so your goal should be to lure away that
few Defenders that voitashek has in the
position
okay so what what are you thinking I
know I know you're the one in the back
you're giving the advice but it's your
idea
go ahead no no it's fine
that's fine that's fine
there's
one
because it is White's turn
so
you know and if you want to avoid that
what would you do
being taken by the night what would you
do as white
yeah
um
yeah so exactly now you you may be
wondering okay
what a random way but it's actually not
that random so sometimes just for the
fact that you fear for something
can help you find the right solution
you're like oh my goodness my queen is
attacked by the night
but it's my move so they can take it
haha so I will take it first
takes now I check and that's sort of the
whole point I want to lure away the
queen from the defense and then I have
this check you go here
check again here and now we do what we
romantically call letter mate
okay and King G7
yep
here King H7
n is silver
very nice so even though you see these
positions they're like oh they're so
slow then Duda goes to over his DN and
it's Bam Bam Bam over
so it was just game over after clean age
six check voice immediately resigned
all right so I wanted to show you this
game but I really wanted to show the
game that I feel inspired
who's playing the world championship
match against England to actually pick
up this line
because there was this guy called
Carlson Magnus Carlsen and he played
against none other than dingler and
himself
it's the same variation
so we're gonna fast forward there here
rookie one Knight D2 Bishop f8 H3 and
instead of going for Pawn D5 break Dane
chooses to keep it all nice and cushy
and just go Rook B8 keep this structure
for now
okay
so
first of all
you may want to think about how you
could gain
some more space in this position
and you'll be like I don't know Theory I
don't know Theory well use your brain
and not the space bar never the spacebar
so we always want to consider
the center right
it's a reasonable thing to consider
so you could go and play some like D4
now I wasn't played in this game but
that doesn't mean that this is not legal
if you can get the center most likely
you're going to be better
right he doesn't really go that way he
actually decides to take here take here
and go wait no he didn't do that exactly
he played before first here and now took
took you might be asking but hey Dennis
Dennis you told us you told us you want
extra space
but I have a response you thought I
didn't prepare for that I did
So my answer is that either you gain
space or or you create a Target
where's our Target
potential
it's B5
so
even though it's not readily apparent
when you're just getting used to the
Spanish the biggest weakness in the
position is the Apon and the B Pawn
because it requires constant defense
and I know the confusion you're like hey
we've got like nine pieces defending the
beep on why is that a weakness
the fact that you're wasting so much
energy defending it
gives the advantage for white because
they got better things to do
than just defending a measly Pawn that's
worth only upon
and I mean these guys are like all
together eight pawns defending B5 so
that's that's mismanagement if you ask
me
so D4
now I really hope none of you are
shocked that we go and play d3d4 here
because
first you create this weakness and then
you create a big Center
and now you can actually claim an
advantage
because we've got a two to one and they
just only got one Pawn in the middle
Knight G6 Knight B three
Rook A8
okay so I already gave a reason why Rook
8 could be a good move and it is indeed
a splendid one by ding
but can anybody tell me what is sort of
the Strategic idea behind the move Rook
B8 to A8
he's looking at the Kingdom
yeah you do get a diagonal you do get it
but also you get an open file
oop those are not my happiest arrows
ever
ah okay anyways
uh
the point is
for one you get rid of this active Rook
which has an open file every Rook you
have you want to have it on the open
file in general
oh no uh we want to have that on the
open file also the thing is that
um
Rook A8
you want to trade
in case you have less space
and at this moment you have much less
space as black you got only one Pawn in
the middle
so every trade is going to favor you
okay
eight Bishop D2 so white is trying to
avoid trades and black is trying to
enforce as much as possible takes takes
Queen C8 King H2 Knight H5
so you look at this position and you're
wondering huh why does this very very
strong player who's actually playing a
world championship match by now put the
Knight on the side of the board now it
should already erase some Flags
something's up
but what is what's up
what's up what's going on here
yeah
they want to attack us a lot hope it
wants to jump to this Square on F4
setting up threats on this Pawn on H3
foreign
so
you may be wondering okay
how are we going to deal with that
and uh Carlson's next move
is brilliant because it does something
very similar that we saw in the previous
game in The Duda game
he goes and plays a move that serves a
dual purpose
no you only panic when it's too late
it's not time to panic yet
you just have to recall there is
potential Target in Black's position
and also a way to over defend this side
of the board
Bishop D3 very very good why
Target
what's good what are we going to do
we're going to go Bishop F1
so
yeah
two birds with one stone
you make sure your king is all guarded
and the B5 Pawn is being attacked or
pressured if you go on ig-1 well you may
defend your king side but you're not
putting pressure on this Pawn on B5
so he's sort of achieving and
accomplishing both in this case now that
four Bishop F1 safely ducking this
bishop into bed
it also has a very nice view on the king
side and now ding's attack is sort of
gone
C6
Pawn takes Pawn takes of course you can
take care because your knight is hanging
detects okay
so
ding managed to over defend the b-pawn
so that's no longer an issue
so we got to look for new pastures
and this is the moment you sort of
Wonder and Magnus wandered okay I've got
all these three pieces which one can I
improve
can we improve the Knight on F3
question number one
yes
oh no when to exchange on E5
when Carlson just did
considerably quickly
um we're gonna talk about why this
capture was good
very shortly
but first let's try to focus at the
problem at hand
and I'll come back to that question
obviously
so which one of these pieces can we
improve or is there a reason to improve
this night
oh what
I'm not sure that like the Knight is on
B3 already
oh you improved that one okay I get it
so where would you put it
good
and it's actually what cousin is going
to do shortly
um yeah this Knight isn't really doing
much right it's just standing there
the closer you could get towards your
opponent's pieces the better and that
Knight isn't doing too much so its value
is sort of low
it's not an F3 it does its job puts
pressure on the e-pawn and it's kind of
fine
so Bishop E3 so Carlson is preparing the
idea of knights if I possibly could go
Knight C5 immediately sometimes in chess
the moves are interchangeable
but he goes Bishop E3 first
and goes Knight C5 now
takes takes so
I had the question you asked me the
question why did we take on E5
well he saw no other way of progressing
in his position he felt well if I trade
here my knight actually will get this
Outpost which otherwise he wouldn't
because the Palm would capture so that
is sort of the concept of taking on E5
otherwise it's not always that
straightforward why would you take on
that square so here let's see 5 takes F6
okay so we improved our Bishop we have
our Knight in the right Square
and is actually only a couple more moves
uh to find for Magnus and he's going to
completely take over
you're going to say why he took with the
pawn instead of the bishop in a moment
and again it's all about realizing
how we can improve our pieces this next
move isn't spectacular however it's
simple and strong
same time
if you just know a basic strategy
and what peace is like
that's what you do
so some people like to talk to their
pieces but you know some pieces are
introverted so I don't approve of that
completely so it's just much better to
know which piece belongs where
and then maybe you can start a
conversation
so here Rook D1 was played
can we tell why we go Rook D1
well we put the Rook on the open file
simple as that
so in chess
there are some Basics Knights to the
outposts
pieces closer to the center and Rooks
you just put them on the open file or a
file that's going to open up so they'll
be there and they'll be ready when
action happens
so there are some simple general
principles you can follow and you don't
always have to come up with a master
plan
so here Rook D6 notice what causlin is
doing he decided I'm gonna plonk that
Knight on D6 whatever you do
is following through his plan and it
turns out it works now if they go here I
could still go here trades you go here I
can over defend this and that's the
point of capturing with the pawn and not
the bishop because now you can create a
past font on D6 that otherwise you
wouldn't have
so this is again sort of thinking a
couple of moves ahead
which makes this play by Magnus very
deep and good of course
so King H7 Rook D6 F5 ding is doing the
best he can he's trying to Muddy Waters
as much as possible however Carlson just
make sure that never works so capture is
here you can't quite take here because
the E Pawn was loose so he captures this
way
Knight D4
problem is that black is all tied up
Knight E5
Queen B1 so
technically
black is not down up not even a single
Pawn
but compared to the value of these
pieces
White's position is overwhelming why
well this Rook attacks this Pawn the
bishop is almost completely useless
while I have pressure on F5 as well and
these doubled pawns are not quite great
so this is what we call
a strategic play and a strategic
Masterpiece where you don't necessarily
win by force like we did in the other
game like in The Duda game it was all
tactics Bam Bam you win but more of just
putting your pieces on ideal squares
while misplacing your opponents and here
uh dig just collapses and it's not his
fault his position is already really
really bad
G6 I mean this wouldn't help either
you'd immediately lose a piece
because I have two Defenders
and you don't have the majority so you
can't capture the piece back with enough
peace
so I'm just winning
so as to go G6 Queen C1 little probing
moves but black is helpless
here takes
G5 it just shows even if you take here I
just take now you lose the pawn and you
can't move that's the worst
here
Rook G8 we need four
96 again he's not taking risks just
trying to improve improve a couple of
his pieces that he has
F six
Bishop D3 and you're gonna cry well no
one else is watching
this queen H7 is incoming that's game
over
so these are the games I wanted to show
you all
um this is preparing like a pro you see
and you look at some examples of how to
play a position this case the Spanish
you kind of get inspired by the game of
your opponent in this case dingler and
even though this is not exactly
um the way you want to play this does
give you a footprint of how you could
play against Damian actually he managed
to win that game in a very good style so
this is how you prepare like a pro thank
you so much for coming and watch
okay
[Music]